hello and welcome to this video playing
or fails 21 and he says hello we don't
have the shortcuts it's odd
usually have those shortcuts weird we
can play high and and so we can just
click for there was short messages like
hello and so on always think this is
kind of kind of useful okay so the
London the London system getting more
and more popular somehow
it's a simple to play opening hm
yeah 97 yeah that's gone 97 trying to
get rid of this bloody night
sure you can keep it in stock to play a
six really tough to play
[Music]
I don't really know what my next plan is
the only good thing is I played this
quite quickly f6 there's always Queen
age five okay he went Queen age five
here you can actually now think about
sacrificing twice there with white which
would be a draw you know this is
something that I would be actually not
unhappy with this is the way to play for
win but it looks pretty chicly very
dubious okay but I mean I don't want to
just make it wrong maybe this is not so
terrible yeah okay this is not terrible
at all actually let's see um I can take
Bishop c5 is interesting what keep the
bishop it's both interesting and or keep
the knight I'm sorry it's both
interesting yes is probably equal
okay now I can go a form that was what I
wanted to do and now try to get an
attack on the kingside myself
unfortunately Oh hmm I wanted to say
unfortunately I cannot play crook mf5
but this is something that is now
possible okay I cannot take this the
Queen here but I don't
I still don't mind that he played this
one looks weakening okay so I take now I
will get five through got five blunders
this rook okay if I play white if I play
Bishop F to Bishop F to rook takes I
take on g3 not working
unfortunately
threaten f3v it's not the most subtle
threat ever but effective wasn't sure
what his best reply was to be honest so
we had this opening I really think white
was in quite comfortable shape maybe I
have to play 97 Here I am I was a little
bit reluctant to do it but I probably
should do this because now it doesn't
have Rudy one and has to go for the
trade after which I should be okay like
even here yeah this is very likely equal
97 I'm TM I'm not happy really yeah g6
he can at least play the double
sacrifice for a draw I think okay
actually not him I have this one Knight
f6 even okay so f5 wasn't necessary but
I think you know he should not play we
should be five this is a strategic
mistake I think you should definitely
take him and by the way I definitely
would have blundered dision absolutely I
have to play g6 first but I didn't see
that so this would have probably won the
game because I would have recaptured
immediately which it takes a strong look
takes is an easy one and this isn't bad
Arab Adam so we have Bishop e5 then
Jim yeah yeah I'm comfortable my bishop
is a bit stronger than his nothing
special but and now with the F pawn
going forward I have some ideas Jim no
you should be three seems best okay
yeah Bishop l3f that looks like a good
move simply stopping it I mean I have a
nice position I think now but nothing
nothing fantastic okay guys thanks for
watching